let's do one more example of
constructing a lewis diagram that might
be a little bit interesting so let's say
we want to construct the lewis structure
or lewis diagram for xenon
difluoride
so pause this video and have a go at
that
all right now let's work through this
together so first step we just have to
account for the valence electrons
xenon right over here it is a noble gas
it has eight valence electrons one two
three four five six seven eight in that
fifth shell it's in the fifth period so
it has eight valence electrons and then
fluorine we have looked at fluorine
multiple times we know that it has seven
valence electrons one two three four
five six seven in that second shell and
we have two of these fluorines so two
times seven and then this gives us a
total of eight plus 14 valence electrons
which gets us to 22
valence electrons in total
now the next step and we've done this
multiple times in multiple videos now is
we would try to
draw the structure with some single
covalent bonds
and we would put xenon as our central
atom because it is less electronegative
than fluorine so let's put a xenon there
and let's put two fluorines on either
side so fluorine there
and a fluorine there and let's set up
some single covalent bonds and so how
many of our valence electrons have we
now accounted for well two in that
in that bond and then two in that bond
so we've accounted for four so minus
four valence electrons we now have a
total of 18 valence electrons now the
next step is we want to allocate them to
our terminal atoms and try to get them
to a full octet each of these fluorines
already have two valence electrons that
they are sharing so we need to give each
of them six more so two
four
six
two
four
six so i've just allocated 12 more
valence electrons so minus 12 valence
electrons means that we still have six
valence electrons left to allocate and
there's only one place where we can
allocate those left over six valence
electrons and that's at the central atom
at the xenon so let's do that so
two
four
and six
and there you have it we have the lewis
diagram the lewis structure for xenon
difluoride now what's interesting here
is our fluorines they have an octet of
valence electrons but what's going on
with xenon xenon has 2 4 6
8
10
valence electrons hanging around so this
is one of those examples of an exception
to the octet rule where we go beyond
eight valence electrons which is
possible for elements in the third or
higher period